et toi
désolé
si tu pouvais aller n'importe où dans le
monde où irais-tu
j'ai toujours voulu faire partie de quelque chose de
plus grand
[Applaudissements]
j'aime cette réponse quelque chose qui dure
qui signifie quelque chose de plus
important que la vie oui
c'est écrit dans les étoiles  je suis une star
si j'avais de l'argent je ne le dépenserais que pour des
choses amusantes tu sais pas des
choses ennuyeuses comme les impôts j'attends juste que
tout
le monde fasse la fête pour toujours
les portes disaient qu'aucun acteur ou chien n'était autorisé
j'ai changé cela
et maintenant vous êtes tous prêts pour quelque chose de
différent
je ne suis pas seul à comprendre [Applaudissements] j'ai tellement de problèmes manny
nous devons vivre maintenant
ce que je fais signifie quelque chose que
vous pensiez que cet enfant avait besoin de vous
c'est plus grand que vous
c'est l'endroit le plus magique du monde
[Applaudissements]
élever
qui  veut me voir f  ight a snake
[Musique]
enfer ouais
toi